Welcome to Epic Games Online Training.
Hi, I'm Sean Lake, and I'm here to take you through the introduction to animation within the engine.
Some of the topics we're going to be covering today are the animation subeditors and features,
as well as importing, exporting animation assets,
and creating a new animation asset within the sequence editor,
creating a socket,
and then finally we'll be animating and baking out an animation within Sequencer.
Now below is a link for the 5.3 animation documentation.
This you can expand upon your knowledge beyond what we will teach today.
Now the project we're going to be using is the one that's noted here,
and we'll be doing a breakdown of each of the folders within it,
and then finally we'll create an import folder within our class folder to get started.
And speaking of, let's get started.